bonsoir le godbout bonsoir c'est l'union
avant d'expliquer sur quoi vous basez
aujourd'hui vous dites essentiellement
que l' équilibre en cinq ans ça va être
quand même difficile ça va quand même
difficile il n'y a pas de doute dans
l'or c'est c'est pas irréalisable mais
de penser qu'on va le faire sans aussi
des impôts sans ralentir la croissance
des dépenses et tout en maintenant les
versements au fonds des générations
probablement qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire les trois en même temps
oui on a des scénarios pour essayer de
voir comment démêler tout ça un peu là
alors sur quelles données économiques
vous vous appuyez aujourd'hui pour faire
vos projections de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire alors les données sur lequel
on s'appuie dans le fond c'est les
données du dernier du portrait que
ministre des finances affaires juin
dernier donc de ce côté là on peut
prendre des données de type maintenir la
croissance des dépenses
on prend également la moyenne des
prévisions des économistes pour la
croissance économique et dans le fond on
regarde également le tout axé sur toutes
les données qui avait dans le portrait
mais on cherche à faire comment on peut
projeter sa pour les dix prochaines
années
oui on établit le scénario le plus
probable le scénario de base de plus
probable de se matérialiser
et donc quand on regarde les données
économiques ont regardé transferts
fédéraux également sont inclus bien sûr
dans vos projections tout à fait donc
c'est une part importante des revenus du
gouvernement du québec qui ont les
regards des leurs dans le fond il a
fallu faire des hypothèses et du côté
des transferts fédéraux ce qu'on a fait
si on omet tenu compte des bonifications
que le gouvernement fédéral a fait en
juillet et en août donc on a tenu compte
de ça ça améliore le portrait du québec
on a tenu compte aussi ou d'un effect
pour être paradoxal mais pour les
transferts en santé
lorsque le lorsque la croissance
économique et pour rendez vous on vous
assure un train une croissance de 3%
mais lorsque l'économie croît plus on en
tient compte également et comme là cette
année un gros choc les transferts quand
même 2,3 mais l'année prochaine la
reprise va être forte alors les
transports vont augmenter plus que ce
qui était prévu en février ou mars
dernier donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour du côté des transports et des roues
pour la santé et pour la péréquation
ben il n'y a pas de réouverture du
dossier avant 2024 25 mai nous on a
projeté comme s'il y avait pas de chance
j'm'en la péréquation que les mêmes
break continuer de s'appliquer et donc
on arrive au résultat qu'on va présenter
un graphique que vous nous avez fourni
qui montre que le ministre girard
pourrait peut-être avoir du mal à
revenir quand même l équilibre
budgétaire
en cinq ans la première année luc 2020
21 c'est le défi de projeter le 15
milliards oui c'est le déficit projeté
avec dans le dans le portrait qui le
fait lui-même le méné cent en juin
dernier
et là on voit qu'il utiliserait la
totalité de la réserve de stabilisation
entre les les surplus accumulés parce
qu'ils permettent d'éponger et donc la
loi sur l'équilibré budgétaire ne
commencerait à s'appliquer qu'en 2021 22
et si on me dira l'application de la loi
il faudrait donc retrouver l'équilibré
budgétaire en 2025 26 et l'on voit selon
notre scénario de base sans hausse
d'impôts ralentissement de la croissance
des dépenses ou maintien du versement au
fonds des générations
on n'a pas l'équilibré en 2025 26,6 nous
manque grosso modo 3.2 milliards et on a
projeté est grosso modo l' équilibre
budgétaire arriverait en 2030 en 2030 ce
soir est donc ça respecteraient pas la
loi
hélas c'est pour ça qu'avec un scénario
de base c'est difficile le ministre lui
misé sur plus de croissance on n'a pas
des chefs à l'écran mais même avec plus
de croissance on n'est pas capable pour
2025 26 de retrouver l'équilibré on le
retrouvera en une année ou deux plus
tard parce que lui dit plus de
croissance
je vais pas faire de rigueur ou
d'austérité budgétaire puis je veux pas
augmenter les taxes et les impôts mais
je rends atteindre mon objectif en 5
c'est çà et là il a c'est là tout le
défi peut-être moyen de concilier des
choses ça sans augmenter les impôts de
manière généralisée une révision des
mesures fiscales est toujours pertinente
s'il ya des mesures qui sont moins
opportune maintenant le coût
d'opportunité de dépenser 1 milliard en
dépenses fiscales est important on
pourrait donc en release est quelqu'un
quelques-unes et là c'est notre pop
d'ouverture nous du côté des dépenses
on est d'avis comme le ménisque du côté
des de la révision des dépenses on
devrait pas restreint de la croissance
se le dire on doit faire l'évaluation
permanente des programmes essayer des
mesures qui sont des programmes sont
moins pertinent on peut les enlever mes
pauvres pour faire de cet édito dépenses
et
évidemment on souhaite le maintien des
trains des versements au fonds des
générations
ouais mais donc est ce que il faut
ouvrir la loi sur l'équilibré budgétaire
d'une part la pour reporter à plus tard
par exemple équilibre légalement et la
loi aussi sur le remboursement de la
dette qui est lié justement au fonds des
générations bennoo en france que ces
deux lois importantes de loi qui ont
assaini les finances publiques du québec
de loi qui procure une bonne santé
financière du gouvernement du québec
je pense qu'il faut quand même les
revoir donc cédé bonne loi mais ils
doivent être adaptées alors ce qu'on
puisse qu'on regarde du côté de la loi
sur l'équilibré budgétaire notamment ce
qu'ils firent pas c'est qu'on peut faire
des déficits lorsque la situation
économique est mauvaise mais la
situation économique
suite au 11 septembre 2001 suite à la
grande récession de 2008 suite au grand
confinement de 2020 c'est pas la même
contraction économique qu'on a subies et
dans tous les corps de cinq ans alors
nous ce qu'on suggère c'est peut-être de
mettre une appréciation à ça et de
permettre aux ministres de retrouver en
trois sets à l'équilibré budgétaire
selon la lille à lyon d'orientation
économique soirée d'ouverture jusqu'à
sept ans donc pourquoi pas ok et du côté
du fonds des générations mais là il ya
deux choses
les seuls qui sont accumulées dans le
fonds des générations ne peuvent servir
au remboursement de la dette soit il
doit pas y avoir d'ambiguïté là dessus
les sommes qui sont collectés qui
doivent être versés au fort des revenus
qu'on appelle dédié doivent être versés
au fonds des générations
nous ce qu'on dit il ya peut-être une
ouverture c'était en ce moment là il ya
3 milliards qu'ils avaient reçus au
fonds des générations mais dans 2000 25
26 et en europe 4 points et 3 milliards
de verser selon toute vraisemblance on
dit dans le contexte déficitaire
actuelle est ce que le ministre pourra
pas dire que certains revenus dédiés
sont temporairement soustrait des
versements au fonds des générations
ils vont dans le fonds consolidé
directement pour retrouver l'équilibré
budgétaire
je pense notamment le menace marceau
avait rajouté en 2013 14
une portion des taxes sur les boissons
alcooliques ça pourrait être sortie
diversement dédié au fonds des
générations il servira rétablir
l'équilibré budgétaire
ok deux propositions intéressantes on
met ça dans le débat public le godbout
remercie pas quoi la prochaine
la prochaine